اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات في
العناوين
اوكرانيا تترقب مساعدات عسكريه امريكيه
وتتهم روسيا بقصر مناطق في الصواريخ
الباليستيه
وزير خارجيه ايران يعلن اجراء مشاورات مع
نظيره السعودي خلال يومين لتحديد موعد
ومكان اجتماعيهما المرتقب
صور فضائيه تكشف عن نشاط كبير بمجمع نووي
في كوريا الشماليه وترصد مفاعلا تجريبيا
يقترب من الاكتمال
وبوادر قلق بعد انتشار القاتل فيروس لا
علاج له وتحذير من السفر الى غينيا
الاستوائيه وتنزانيا
صباح الخير مع تصاعدي حده المعارك في
اوكرانيا تترقب كييف اعلانا هاما من
واشنطن غدا الاثنين عن حزمه مساعدات جديده
من المساعدات العسكريه الدعم الامريكي
ياتي تزامنا مع اعلان كييف عن استخدامها
ذخائر الهجوم المباشر عاليه الدقه والتي
طلبت واشنطن بالمزيد منها في المقابل
روسيا من جانبها اعلنت عن زياده انتاج
السلاح بكافه انواعه ازدياد تدفق الاسلحه
على الجانبين الروسي والاوكراني مشاهدينا
انعكس على ارض المعرقه المعركه فقد اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه التصدي لهجوم
اوكرانيين مشترك وذلك براجمات الصواريخ
متعدده الاطلاق من بينها صواريخ هاي مارس
على جنوب دونيتك وقال المتحدث باسم
الوزاره ان القوات الروسيه اسقطت ثلاث
طائرات مسيره اوكرانيه بالاضافه الى تدمير
مجموعتي استطلاع اوكرانيا وفي ظل التصعيد
الروسي الاوكراني في جبه
اعلنت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان روسيا
سنه اربعين هجوما صاروخيا على مناطق
ماهوله بالسكان واستهدفت افديفكا في دنيتك
بصواريخ باليستيه وذلك بحسب هيئه الاركان
وبمزات التصعيد العسكري تترقب اوكرانيا
حزمه المساعدات الامريكيه الجديده والتي
قد تصل قيمتها الى مليارين و600 مليون
دولار المساعدات تهدف لانجاح هجوم الربيع
الذي تستعد له اوكرانيا ضد الجيش الروسي
وتشمل الحزم الامريكي رادارات للمراقبه
الجويه وصاروخ مضاده للدبابات وشاحنات
لنقل الوقود وقال ثلاثه مسؤولين امريكيين
انه من المتوقع ان تتضمن قائمه العدد سته
انواع من الذخائر بينها ذخائر الدبابات
ومن المقرر ايضا ادراج ذخائر جويه دقيقه
ومعدات جسور قد تستخدمه اوكرانيا للهجوم
على مواقع روسيه اضافه الى مركبات انقاذ
لمساعدات لمساعده المعدات الثقيله المطلعه
مثل الدبابات وقذائف اضافيه لمنظومه ناسا
ناساامس للدفاع الجوي والتي قدمتها
الولايات المتحده وحلفائها الى كيف
وقبل وصول الدعم الامريكي طلبت كييف من
بولندا 100 مدرعه متعدده المهام ومن طراز
رسوماك التي تصنعها بترخيص من فنلندا
حامله الجنود المدرعه رسومات
مدرعه متعدده المهام
ذات ثماني عجلات
تنتجها بولندا بترخيص من فنلندا
وتوصف بالاكثر حمايه
ومسلحه بمدفع عيار 30 ملم
المدرع محصنه ضد الالغام من الدرجه الاولى
[موسيقى]
وقادره على حمل عشره جنود
وهي مجهزه بصواريخ سبايك الموجهه المضاده
للدبابات
وهي مجهزه ايضا بمحرك بقوه
6303 احصنه
معنى من كييف اوراق رمضان رئيس مركز
الاوراس للدراسات الاستراتيجيه اهلا بك
معنا السيد رمضان اذا
روسيا تصدت لهجوم اوكرانيا على منطقه دنيت
بالامس واليوم اوكرانيا تطالب بالمزيد من
الصواريخ او الذخائر الدقيقه عاليه الدقه
من واشنطن وتطالب ايضا بولندا بمدرعات
روسو ماك لماذا تطالب بهذه الاسلحه الان
تحديدا اوكرانيا
المدرعه يوفي استعمالها من اجل الاجلاء
الجرحى يعني الجنود الذين يعني يتواجدون
في حصار هذه المرحله يعني
هناك محاوله اذا لم يتمكن الاوكران فهم
سينسحبون يعني هذا كذلك
هذه المهمه ستكون مهمه من جهه اخرى الدوله
الاوكرانيه والجيش الاوكراني
بهجوم معاكس على محور من المحاور ربما
سيباغت الروس ربح على يعني احتمالا على
الجبهه الجنوبيه في حال ان الاستراتيجيه
الاوكرانيه
ذهبت باستعمال ما يعرف
المسيرات الموجهه وهو يعني قوي لاختراق
الدفاعات فان هذه المدرعات المتعدده
المهام ستكون جد مهمه
لحل الكثير من المسائل اولا تكون الضاربه
للدفاعات الروسيه وتكون مهمه من اجل نقل
المشاه وكذلك النقل
وكذلك طبعا في الميدان تستعمل اسعاف
للجرحى حتى القتلى هذه مهمه اذن هذه
المدرعات سيده اوراك بالفعل هي مضاده
للمتفجرات بشكل كبير ولكنها تقل فقط 10
جنود على متنها هل هي كافيه لانقاذ عدد
كافي من المصابين
المساله ان
اكثر من مئه قطعه لان هذا الرسومات تاتي
كذلك
من نفس الجمله او من نفس الطراز لمدرعات
اخرى امريكيه وكذلك اوروبيه
تواجد وهي تتواجد الان هذا العدد غير كافي
لكن اضافه الى ما وصل
يعني هناك سريه للكثير ما وصل
الى فهذا النوع سيكون مهم بما يعرف اذا
اخترقات الخاطبه المباغه للدفاعات الروسيه
وهي مهمه ومتعدده المهام يعني هي كافيه
وحقيقه وخاصه بالنسبه للقوات النخبه
الخاصه وليس للمشاه العاديين السؤال
الاجابه السؤال هي مهمه وستعتبر يعني
ضاربه وهي يعني اذا كان حقا حق الملغم فهي
كانت اهميه الاسلحه التي تطالب بها
اوكرانيا في هذا التوقيت ولكن واشنطن يعني
هناك ارتقاب لان تعلن لي على حزمه مساعدات
غدا بقيمه 2.6 مليار دولار الى اوكرانيا
هل هذه المساعدات تجهيزا لمعركه الربيع
المرتقبه هل هي كافيه هل ستصل الى
اوكرانيا في الموعد المحدد سيد رمضان
ربما في الحمله الصيفيه او حتى الحمله
التي ستاتي فيه الخريف لان هذا سيء اولا
ستصل يجب تدريبها يجب تشكيل هذه الاذرع
وهناك عمل
تقني فني سياخذ مده وتدريبات كذلك على
المعدات اظن في تلك المرحله ستكون مهمه
عندما يبدا الجيش الاوكراني فيما يعرف
بالحمله العكسيه او الهجوم المعاكس فهي
اظن ستكون في التوقيت اما ما يخص الربيع
الوقت لن يكفي من اجل
تشغيل ما يعرف بالمجموعات الضاربه او
المجموعات للنخب الخاصه والتي تتدرب الان
في الدول الاوروبيه وربما حتى في الولايات
المتحده نحن نتكلم عن حمله وربما القريب
طيب بعيدا عن الدعم العسكري سيد رمضان
والقصف سنتوقف مع موقف كييف من تولي روسيا
رئاسه مجلس الامن الدوريه ونعود اليك
الصياد رمضان الان مشاهدينا وصف الرئيس
الاوكراني
روسيا الرئاسه الدوريه لمجلس الامن التابع
للامم المتحده وصفه بالامر السخيف واضافت
ان تولي روسيا هذه المهمه في مجلس الامن
يكشف عن افلاس تام للمؤسسات الدوليه وفق
تعبيره اعود اليك سيد رمضان رئيس مركز
الاوراس للدراسات الاستراتيجيه يعني تعليق
كييف على تولي روسيا رئاسه مجلس الامن
بالسخيف لماذا هو كذلك لماذا تصفه بهذا
الوصف روسيا هي العضو الدائم والعضو اساسي
في مجلس الامن وهذه مجرد دوريه تدور على
الاعضاء والان اصبح دور روسيا
لهذا السؤال تاريخ اولا روسيا كانت من
الدوله الضامنه لسياده اوكرانيا بموجب ما
يعرف بمذكره وقامت بحرق ذلك هي الدوله
التي
تعتبرنا في حال لم توافق اوكرانيا على وضع
او اسلحه نيتو على اراضيها
لكن في هذه الحاله نحن الان نتواجد في
حاله حرب وحاله التدمير واستدمار متبادل
فالدوله الروسيه بالنسبه لاوكرانيا فهي
خارقه لانظم القانون الدولي ومواثيق الامن
الدولي ومنظمه
في هذه الحاله هي ادت واعتدت على سياده
وعلى وحده وسلامه التراب الدوله وهي عضو
في ذلك المنتظم طبعا
الموقف الاوكراني منطقي يعني انها تراس
الدوله خارقه للقانون بمنظمه
واتى في يوم واحد ابريل الذي يعتبر يوم
يعني
الهزل والامور الاخرى يعني كذلك هذا الامر
بدا يتداول
اما من الناحيه الجديه طبعا من حق الدوله
الاوكرانيه ان تصف روسيا وتصف هذه ما يعرف
دور او رئاسه روسيا
للمجلس الامن الدولي الذي يجب ان يرعى ان
تكون القانون الدول المنتظم الدولي ان
يطبق
بكل
ذلك وتطلب باع
اده هيكله وتنظيم واعاده تشكيل تنظيم جديد
لن يكون للرسول فيه دور بهذا الشيء
السيد رمضان هل بالامكان المساس بعضويه
روسيا في مجلس الامن الدولي شكرا لك من
كييف اوراق رمضان رئيس مركز الاوراس
للدراسات الاستراتيجيه
اكد الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان
التعاون مع بيلاروسيا يجري بشكل فعال رغم
العقوبات الغربيه جاء ذلك خلال اتصال اجره
بوتين مع نظيره البيلاروسي اليكساندر
لوكاشينكو بمناسبه يوم الوحده بين البلدين
حيث شدد بوتين على ضروره التصدي للعقوبات
الغربيه وابدت بيلاروسيا استعدادها لنشر
اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه روسيه على اراضيها
مؤكده ان خطر انتشار النيتو في دول الجوار
دفعها لاتخاذ ذلك القرار ونفت صحيفه
الاتهامات الموجهه ضد مراسلها ايفان
الذي اعتقلته روسيا الاسبوع الماضي
للاشتباه في قيامه بالتجسس وطالبه السلطات
الروسيه بالافراج الفوري عنه وفي تغريده
قالت الصحيفه انها تعتبر الاتهامات
الموجهه الى صحافيها اهانه قاسيه لحريه
الصحافه مشدده على انه لا ينبغي احتجاز اي
مراسل لمجرد القيام بعمله
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها
غاره اسرائيليه جديده على مواقع ايرانيه
في سوريا ومقتل مستشار الحرس الثوري في
غاره سابقه
حياكم الله من جديد افادت وكاله ايرنا
الايرانيه بان وزير خارجيه ايران حسين عبد
الله سيجري اتصالا هاتفيا مع وزير
الخارجيه السعودي فيصل بن فرحان وذلك
لتحديد موعد ومكان اللقاء بينهما وقال عبد
الله انه سيجري مشاورات مع نظيره السعودي
خلال اليومين المقبلين وذلك لوضع لمسات
الاخيره على لقائهما المرتقب الى اسرائيل
حيث اسفل القصف الاسرائيلي الذي استهدف
مواقع ايرانيه الجمعه في سوريا عن مقتل
مستشار عسكري ثاني للحرس الثوري الايراني
وكاله انباء مهر الايرانيه شبه الرسميه
افادت بان مقداد مقداني قتل متاثرا بجروحه
في الغاره التي شنتها اسرائيل الجمعه
الماضيه قتل فيها ايضا مستشار عسكري اخر
في الحرس الثوري من جانبه قال مدير المرصد
السوري لحقوق الانسان للعربيه قال ان
القصف الاسرائيلي الاخير الذي نفذ امس
السبت استهدف مطار العسكري غربه مدينه حمص
وهناك معلومات مشاهدينا مؤكده حول وقوع
قتلى سوريين في منطقه البحوث العلميه حيث
يتواجد خبراء اسلحه ايرانيين
في اليمن كشفت مياه الامطار عن كميات
كبيره من الالغام المدفونه على ممرات
السيول في مارب وقال سكان محليون في منطقه
حرير بجنوب محافظه مارب التي تشهد مواجهه
عسكريه بين قوات الحكومه اليمينيه او
اليمنيه وجماعات الحوثي قالوا ان السيول
جرفت عشرات الالغام وباتت مكشوفه وسط
وديان المنطقه كما ذكر تقرير سابق
مشاهدينا تقرير لنزع الالغام ان اجمالي
الالغام والذخائر غير المتفجره والتي تم
نزعها وصلت الى اكثر من 393 الف لغم ذخيره
كانت قد زرعتها ميليشيات الحوثي في
الاراضي اليمنيه
افدى موقع بحث امريكي بان صورا التقطتها
الاقمار الصناعيه اظهرت مستوى عالي من
النشاط في بيونغيون وهو الموقع النووي
الرئيسي في كوريا الشماليه وذلك بعد ان
امر زعيم البلاد بزياده انتاج وقود
القنابل لتوزيع ترسانه البلاد النوويه
وقال موقع 38 نورث الالكتروني وهو المعني
بمراقبه كوريا الشماليه قال ان النشاط
الذي تم رصده وفقا لصور التقطت يومين
الثالث والسابع عشر من مارس يمكن ان يشير
الى ان مفاعلا تجريبيا بقوه خمسه ميجاوات
يعمل بالماء الخفيف في موقع
يقترب من الاكتمال والانتقال الى مرحله
التشغيل هذا وافادت وسائل اعلام كوريا
الشماليه ان بيون يون لا تدلي باحاديث
فارغه وذلك بشان قدراتها النوويه مضيفه ان
الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه تنخرطان
في سلوك خاطئ سيعرض الدولتين لخطر كبير
اضافت ايضا انه يتعين على الولايات
المتحده واتباعها الا ينسوا ابدا حقيقه ان
كوريا الشماليه لديها القدره على الهجوم
النووي
قال وزير الخارجيه اليابانيه يوشيماسا
هياتشي انه ابلغ نظيره الصيني على حرص
طوكيو على الامن والاستقرار في خليج
تايوان واشار في مؤتمر صحفي الى انه اتفقا
مع نظيره الصيني على ضروره فتح حوار بين
البلدين على جميع المستويات وخاصه فيما
يتعلق برفع القيود عن صادرات الاغذيه
اليابانيه
اعلنت هيئه تحرير لوموند والبراسيون ان
مراسلتي الصحفيتين الفرنسيه طردتان او
طردتان من بوركينا فاسو ووصف ووصفتا
الاجراء بانه تعسفي وغير مقبول وكشفت
صحيفه
في بوركينا فاسو صوفي جوس طردت من البلاد
في الوقت نفسه مع زميلتها من البراسيون
انيس فيفر من جهتها قالت الليبراسيون ان
حريه الصحافه في بوركينا فاسو مهدده بشكل
كبير موضحه ان مراسلتها وزميلتها في
الموند وصلت الى باريس
مستمرون معكم مشاهدينا ونتابع قبل محاكمه
ترامب شرطه نيويورك تتاهب وتنتشر كافه
عناصرها
[موسيقى]
اوكرانيا تترقب مساعدات عسكريه امريكيه
وتتهم روسيا بقصف مناطق في دونيسك
بالصواريخ الباليستيه
وزير خارجيه ايران يعلن اجراء مشاورات مع
نظيره السعودي خلال يومين لتحديد موعد
ومكان اجتماعهما المرتقب
صور فضائيه تكشف عن نشاط كبير في مجمع
نووي بكوريا الشماليه وترصد مفاعلا
تجريبيا يقترب من الاكتمال
بوادر قلق بعد انتشار ماربورج القاتل
فيروس لا علاج له وتحذير من السفر الى
غينيا الاستوائيه وتنزانيا
احييكم من جديد حضرت مراكز السيطره على
الامراض الاميركيه سي دي سي المسافرين الى
غينيا الاستوائيه وتنزانيا من الاصابه
بفيروس ماربر القاتل موضحه انها ارسلت
طاقما من الخبراء للمساعده في وقف تفشي
المرض ووفق منظمه الصحه العالميه اعلنت
غينيا الاستوائيه في فبراير ظهور اول حاله
لفيروس
وسجلت 9 حالات مؤكده توفوا جميعا مع
الاشتباه بعشرنا اصابه اخرى اما في
تنزانيا رصدت السلطات ثمان اصابات توفي
منهم خمسه اشخاص حتى الان
ما لبث العالم ان يلتقط انفاسه بعد وباء
كورونا حتى اتاه فيروس مرعب اخر يدعى
ماربر الفيروس اثار القلق بسبب انه لا
يوجد حتى الان لقاح او دواء لعلاج والذي
تبدا اعراضه بالصداع والحمى النزيفيه
والام العضلات وبعد ثلاثه ايام يعاني
المصاب من اسهال والام في المعده وغثيان
وقيء وطفح جلدي والكثير من المضاعفات
الاخرى وهي اعراض قد تنتهي به الى الموت
بعد ثمانيه الى تسعه ايام اثر النزيف
الحاد والصدمه وربما المخيف اكثر مشاهدينا
ان معدلات الوفيات تصل الى 88% خبراء
الصحه اوضحوا ان الوقايه قد تكون امرا
صعبا ولكن يجب استخدام وسائل الحمار
الحمايه كارتداء القفازات والاقنعه
والكمامات اما عن انتشار العدوى فنتحدث عن
طريق الاتصال المباشر بين البشر خاصه
المرتبط بالسوائل مثل الدم او اللعاب وعن
تاريخ قيل ان خفاش الفاكهه هو سبب الرئيسي
للعدوى حيث اكتشف او اكتشف لاول مره قبل
اكثر من نصف قرن في بلده ماربرج الالمانيه
من لندن ينضموا الينا الباحث في علم
الفيروسات واللقاحات الدكتور عمار الخميسي
اهلا بك دكتور القلق لدى الناس اصبح اكثر
بعد جائحه كورونا الى اي مدى هو بالفعل
مقلق
صباح الخير وتحياتي لكم وشكرا على استضافه
بالتاكيد هو ما حيكون مثل كورونا فيروس
كورونا فيروس كورونا فيروس ينتقل عن طريق
الهواء بشكل كبير جدا سرعه انتشاره عاليه
جدا اكثر من فيروس مبلغ بنسبه عاليه
وكبيره جدا
هذا الفيروس ينتقل عن طريق التلامس ملامسه
المريض المصاب المواد المستعمله الاسطح
الملوثه الدم الملوث البراز البول واللعاب
مالته كذلك عن طريق الجوز طبعا اما عن
طريق التنفس هو ينتقل ولكن بشرط واحد ان
يكون هناك كميه كبيره من الفيروسات تنتقل
من الشخص المصاب للشخص السليم وبتركيز
عالي وبكون بغرف مغلقه تقريبا
انه قدرت ان تحد من الفيروس للاسف الشديد
الشهر الماضي سمعنا في تنزانيا ودول غلب
افريقيا اخرى بدا ينتشر بها كذلك
لعزل تلك الدول ربما منع السفر اليها ومنع
الرحلات منها واليها ام لا حاجه لذلك
اسف كنت اسالك دكتور عن احتماليه عزل تلك
الدول تلك الدول او اهميه عزلها هل هناك
اهميه لذلك
حقيقه هذا قرار سياسي واقتصادي كبير جدا
بالوقت الحاضر انتشاره الحقيقه معلومات
عنه بافريقيا مداء انتشار الحالات
الاصابات قليله غير كافيه جدا اسمه هناك
دول انا ذاكره يوميا عن تقارير خمس وفيات
في دوله معينه في افريقيا 10 وفيات في
دوله اخرى بمرض يسمى بالمرض الغامض غامض
اشياء غير معروفه ولكن يكون نفس الفيروس
بس اعتقد اذا انتشر بشكل واضح في افريقيا
يجب ان تعزى لانه هذا الفيروس لا اله علاج
ولا الى لقاح بالحديث عن العلاج يعني هو
يندرج او ينحدر من سلاله الابولا الا يمكن
استخدام علاجات الابوله له
طبعا الفيروسات النفسيه كثيره من ضمنها
كشف الى لقاح هناك اثنين فيروسات ايضا من
النفسيه الها لقاح الان
لقاح تطويري بس حتى يظهر للعلن بين ثلاثه
اشهر الى سته اشهر كذلك نسبه انتاجه مو
بعشرات الملايين او مئات الملايين من
الجراح بالنسبه انت نسبه انتاجها بسيطه
جدا ممكن يحتاج ضخ اموال عاليه مليار
عشرات الملايين من الدولارات تضخ الى
شركات الادويه لانتاج هذا النوع من اللقاح
خلاثات اشهر او سته اشهر ولكن ايضا
الشركات مثل هذا اللقاح لازم تبيعه تريد
تبيعه ذلك يجب ان يكون هناك ضخ اموال اله
طيب واضح شكرا لكن من لندن الباحث في علم
الفيروسات واللقاحات الدكتور عمار الخميسي
مشاهدينا حاله من التاهب تشهدها البلده
قبل مثول الرئيس الامريكي سابق دونالد
ترامب امام المحكمه الثلاثاء وذلك بالتهم
المرتبطه بدفع 130 الف دولار لممثله
الافلام الاباحيه
لشراء صمتها الحدث الذي يثير الراي العام
الامريكي دفع شرطه نيويورك للتاهب ووضع كل
عناصرها التي تضم 36 الف شرطي و19 الف
مدني بالانتشاري بلباسهم الرسمي على الطرق
العامه وذلك لمده اسبوع بحسب مصادر
تلفزيون ام بي سي ومن جهته كشف المتحدث
باسم شرطه نيويورك في تصريحات صحفيه تاهب
الشرطه ياتي للرد على اي تجاوزات قد تحدث
ما يضمن سير حياه الناس بشكل طبيعي طبعا
في الاثناء كشفت وكاله ونقلا عن مصدر مطلع
في فريق ترامب القانوني ان الفريق بسبب
دراسه امكانيه نقل قضيته من محكمه منهاتن
الى محكمه اخرى
واكد ذات المصدر ان دفاع ترامب يخشى عدم
حصول موكله على محاكمه عادله في منهات الا
ان الفريق القانوني ينتظر الحصول على
لائحه الاتهام المفصله قبل تقديمه طلب نقل
القضيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ضرب اعصار عنيف منطقه ليتل راك في ولايه
اركنسوس مما اسفر عن مقتل شخصين على الاقل
واصابه العشرات تسبب هذا الاعصار ايضا
بهدم اسقف وجدران العديد من المباني
والمنازل وسقوط الاشجار وخطوط الكهرباء
وذلك وفق المسؤولين في تلك الولايه
[موسيقى]
مواطن افغاني فقير يتجول في شوارع العاصمه
كابول في هذا الشهر الفضيل ليبيع اقداح
الوضوء في مهنه لا تدر عليه ما يكفيه من
المال ليرجع في اخر المطافي الى هذا
المسجد للافطار الجماعي والمجاني كما ترى
ابيع هذه الاقداح في الشوارع واتي الى هذا
المسجد لتناول الفطور ثم ارجع لعملي
تتناول نسبه كبيره من الافغاني افطار
رمضان في المساجد وفي اماكن اخرى في حلقات
الفطور الجماعي حيث يحضر كل واحد ما تيسر
له من الطعام ليشارك في افطار جماعي وفي
بعض المساجد يقدم المحسنين افطارا جماعيا
مجانيا
نقدم هنا افطارا جماعيا بشكل يومي في
رمضان ويحضره الفام من الفقراء بينهم
اطفال ورجال وسيدات والترتيبات الافطار
منتظمه ما شاء الله لرمضان نكهه شرقيه
طاغيه على افغانستان حيث يستقبل الشعب
الافغاني رمضان بعادات وتقاليد موروثه منذ
عقود فميسور الحالي يغيرون اساس منازلهم
في رمضان اما الفقراء فيعبدون الى تنظيف
اثاثهم حفاوه برمضان فكل شيء يعد هنا من
اجل شهر رمضان
كالخبز والحلويات والمخللات
للافغاني على تنوعهم العرقي والقومي عادات
وتقاليد في رمضان من الممكن جمعها في
كلمتين اثنتين هما الكرم والتقارب ويظهر
ذلك في مظهرين اثنين بالموائد الجماعيه
وصلاه التراويح عبد النادر العربيه كابول
الى عالم الفن والفنانين تخوض الفنانه
المصريه روجينا ماراثون الدراما الرمضانيه
هذا العام في مسلسل ستهم الى جانب مجموعه
من النجوم لتروي اربعه قصص حقيقيه لسيدات
مكافحات من المجتمع المزيد عن كواليس
العمل في الدراما مع سهى الوعل واعداد
ايهام القاسم
[موسيقى]
اقول لك على حاجه وما تنسيها
في حاجه ادي
ما عرفش كيف الناس بتدافع عنك
حتى وانت كيف الميتين
[موسيقى]
مرحبا في اجتماعي شخصيه امراه يموت زوجها
في مسلسل لتتخلى عن ثوب النساء وترتدي ثوب
الرجال من اجل الكفاح للكسب الحلال لقمه
العيش حيث تتعرض للعديد من المشاكل
والازمات بدايه من دخولها فستان ابيض على
اياد نصار اللي يلعب دور زوجها في العمل
وحملها طفل على يديها والدخول في سوى
العزاء وارتداء ثوب الرجال مرورا
بمعاناتها للعيش بالحلال والكفاح قصه ليست
جديده وشخصيه تكررت عده مرات في الدراما
الجديد هذه المره القصه مختلفه تماما يعني
احنا عمرنا ما شفنا قصه ست ارتدت زي راجل
وبقت راجل وبتعمل اعمال الرجال يعني كنا
متخيلين في نموذج واحد في المجتمع بهذا
الشكل اكتشفنا انه في اكثر من نموذج في
المجتمع لستات اشتغلت في حاجات كتيره قوي
ولكن مهنه تناسب الرجل وليس المراه فعشان
كده انا بشوف ان ده حاجه مختلفه في
المسلسل دم من الافكار والمشاريع اللي
كانت عندي بقالها كتير جوايا
وبالتالي في يوم كده يعني
قال يعني زي هاجس وواضح وان انا حابب اعمل
الشخصيه دي والتركيبه دي والشكل العام
للمشروع ده
والكلام ده كان في رمضان اللي فات الحقيقه
يعني قبل انتهاء الشهر الكريم واتكلمت
معاها روجينا واخذنا قرار ان شاء الله ان
احنا يبقى ده مشروعنا القادم
للمراه في صوره عمل درامي وهو من تاليف
ناصر عبد الرحمن واخراج رؤوف عبد العزيز
في ثاني تعاون ما بينهم مع روجينا بعد
مسلسل الانحراف اللي تصدر ترند جوجل اكثر
من مره في رمضان الماضي عمل اجتماعي
الصعيدي عن المراه الصعيديه اللي هي كرمها
الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي في في الايام
الاخيره هي قصه حقيقيه اتمنى بس ان هي
تلمس الناس وهم كده كده عارفين الحاج
بسيطه وعارفين قصتها يعني
فهيتعاطفوا جدا معها يا رب يخشوا في قصه
قوي هو طبعا حاجات متجانسه في بعض ليه
علاقه بكذا مشكله
وكذا لاين لمشاكل كثير بتحصل لحد دلوقتي
يعني في الصعيد وبعدين انا ما اقدرش اقول
رايي في ورق الاستاذ يعني ده يعني رايي لا
يذكر طبعا بالنسبه لتاريخه بس بس ده حقيقي
هو بيقدم حاجات مختلفه ومشاكل
لجيل دلوقتي وجي كده وهيحصل
[موسيقى]
في الختام نذكر بالعناوين
اوكرانيا تترقب بمساعدات عسكريه امريكيه
وتتهم روسيا بقصر مناطق في دنيتك
بالصواريخ الباليستيه
وزير خارجيه ايران يعلن اجراء مشاورات مع
نظيره السعودي خلال يومين لتحديد موعد
ومكان اجتماعيهما المرتقب
صور فضائيات تكشف عن نشاط كبير في مجمع
نووي في كوريا الشماليه وترصد مفاعلا
تجريبيا يقترب من الاكتمال
وبوادر قلق بعد انتشار ماربورج القاتل
فيروز لا علاج له وتحذير من السفر الى
غينيا الاستوائيه وتنزانيا
في امان الله مشاهدينا يلقاكم الزميل نايف
الاحمر على راس الساعه
[موسيقى]